the loire river in france is famous for
the historic castles dotted along its
banks
it's also famously a shallow river
but with water levels at near record
lows even the locals are shocked
it makes me sad because i grew up in the
village
and i've never seen the river like this
we used to go to the water holes over
there with the children and fish because
the water wasn't too hot
now there's just algae and frogs left
the reduction in water has been
disastrous for much of the area's
ecosystem
many islands are now connected to the
shore cutting off various waterways
fish have been robbed of the space they
need to survive and reduced to living in
ponds
scientists say the current low water
level is something of a wider wake-up
call
the low water level this year is quite
exceptional
it's due to a major deficit in rainfall
that began last winter
it's led to many small tributaries of
the lore to dry up
with france currently facing severe
droughts in several regions in
torrential rain and flooding in others
many experts are calling for a rethink
when it comes to the use of essential
natural resources
climate change is underway it's
undeniable and it must encourage us to
reflect on our rules for sharing water
resources we must understand that we're
all affected
and with extreme weather events only set
to increase in the future the issue is
not going away anytime soon